عندما اندلعت الحرب في سوريا ،
عشنا جميعًا في حالة إنكار تام على افتراض
أنه شيء يستمر لمدة شهرين
وسيمر قريبًا مثل سحابة ثقيلة داكنة ،
ومن المؤسف أن سحابة أورت لم
تمر بل تحولت إلى أسوأ
عاصفة شهدتها البلاد.  أجيال عديدة من
الصعب أن تنتهي برؤية وطنك
مجروحًا للغاية ولا يمكنك فعل أي شيء حيال
ذلك ، من المؤلم أن تعيش في حزن
على ذكريات الماضي والخوف من
كل ثانية من الحاضر وفي
قلق من مستقبل تعرفك.  قد
لا تصل إلى أنها كابوس ،
إنها أغنية ساحقة ، لكن هذا لا
يعني أبدًا أننا لن نتألق مرة أخرى
قبل ثلاثة أشهر كنت أعمل في مشروع بحث
وكان لدي هذا
السؤال المتعلق بالإحصاءات ، لذلك أرسلت أحد
أصدقائي عبر الإنترنت في بنما يسأل  له
ماذا يفعل وسأل URI Syria وقلت
نعم وقد صُدم تمامًا لأنه
كان يبحث بجدية عن رجل في سوريا
فقط أخفوا يا رفاق يركزون على عدم التعرض
للقصف وكنت كذلك ، فهذا يعني
الكثير من التركيز على عدم القيام بذلك  تعرضت للقصف هنا ،
لكنني لا أستطيع فعل
أي شيء في انتظار انتهاء هذه الحرب.
الملاجئ ، لقد أحزنني كيف
يرى العالم لنا الآن كيف أصبح
مرتبطًا جدًا بكل شيء أينما تم
ذكر سوريا ، يجب أن تكون
محادثتنا حوله حتى لو بحثت في Google عن
سوريا الآن ، فلن تجد الآن سوى صور
الدمار والجثث إلى جانب
أطنان من التقارير و  إحصائيات عن مقدار
ما نخسره مع كل شخص
ثانٍ ، ثم بدأت أفكر في أنه لا يوجد
شيء يجب
القيام به ، نحن بحاجة إلى مواصلة المضي قدمًا في
مستقبلنا لأن الطلاب
يمثلون خطرًا شديدًا ، حيث تم تحطيم الكثير من الأحلام
يبدو أن الكثير من الخطط المستقبلية
غامضة جدًا وحتى الآن في الوقت الحالي ،
لكن لا يمكننا أبدًا أن نستقر
لكوننا ضحايا لظروفنا
لا يمكننا أبدًا أن نتخلى عنها ، ولكن ما هو
السبيل للخروج من الدور الذي يجب أن نأخذه في
هذه الفوضى  ج- الوضع الذي نحن في حالة
جيدة قضيت أيامًا أفكر وأفكر في
القراءة وإجراء المقابلات مع العديد من
العقول العظيمة داخل سوريا وخارجها
وتوصلت إلى استنتاج شخصي وهو أننا
كطلاب سوريين ، والشباب السوري لدينا
واجب نهائي في هذه الأثناء وهو كذلك.
فقط للحفاظ على التعليم ، نحتاج إلى الحفاظ
على تعليمنا من أجل بلدنا من
أجل مستقبل أفضل ولعهد ما بعد السلام
، وهو قادم لا يمكن أن يستمر أي إرهاب
إلى الأبد ، نحن نعلم فقط أننا نحتاج فقط
أن نكون مستعدين جيدًا لإعادة البناء
بلدنا يعيد بنائه بشكل أكبر وأفضل
مما كان عليه قبل الحرب ، لذا نعم
التعليم منقذ ، إنه
قوة أنا شخصياً أراها
استثمارًا سيؤتي ثماره بالتأكيد
يومًا ما
الكثير من النضالات وأنا أعلم أن
الكثير من صراعاتنا  لقد
انقطع تعليم الأصدقاء والزملاء ، حيث عاش العديد منهم
في مناطق ساخنة ولم يتمكنوا من الوصول إلى
مؤسساتهم التعليمية ، وأنا أعلم أن
الحياة ليست كلها ورود هنا خاصة
مع مشاكل مثل الكهرباء وارتفاع
تكاليف المعيشة والاختباء
أنا أعلم أن الحرب حطمت
العديد من الطلاب وتركتهم
مشردين معاقين أو طلبوا اللجوء في بلدان أخرى ،
لكنني أعلم أنه مرة أخرى
لا يمكننا التخلي عن امتلاكنا لإمكانات
غير محدودة ، فنحن الآن جيل ضائع
نحتاج إلى إظهاره  العالم
الذي يزن أكثر من مجرد
سكان مصابين الآن ، دعني أخبرك
كيف نجحنا أنا وأصدقائي في
التغلب على مدى السنوات الخمس الماضية ، وتمكنا من
تطبيقه في مدرسة الطب ولدي
سبب للاعتقاد بأنه يمكنك جميعًا التقدم بطلب
في جميع مجالات تعليمك ، في
الواقع ، أداتنا السحرية هي
استخدام الإنترنت ، نعم لدينا ضعيف شبه
مكسور واتصالي أعلم أنه يمكن أن يكون
محرضًا على السكتة الدماغية ولكن بالنظر إلى
نصف كوب ممتلئ ، ما زلنا نعيش
في رفاهية تصفح فيناي  لذا استخدمها
لا تضيع الفرصة بالنسبة لي
وبالنسبة للغالبية العظمى من أصدقائي ، فنحن نوفر
اتصال إنترنت موثوق للغاية
أثناء دراستنا ، استخدمنا
مواقع الويب التعليمية على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
دورات تدريبية مفتوحة على الإنترنت لتحسين
تتعلم قدراتنا أشياء جديدة وتعوض
عن أي نقص في معرفتنا ،
فنحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا للحفاظ
على تأهيلنا لرحلة سريرية وأكاديمية مدى الحياة
ولا يمكن لأي حرب أن تمنعنا أبدًا
لإعطائك مزيدًا من التفاصيل حول كيفية عملنا  استخدام
الإنترنت ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والبدء
بـ Facebook ، يمكن استخدام Facebook
لغرضين رئيسيين ، أحدهما نشر
صورك وكيف تشعر كل 15
ثانية لإصابة الأشخاص بالإسهال واثنان
يستخدمونها لشيء أكثر فائدة
مثل التعلم بالنسبة لنا.
أداة تعليمية رائعة اتبعناها العديد
من الصفحات التعليمية التي تم التحقق منها تستخدم الكثير من
المنشورات المتعلقة بالعلوم والطبية لتجنب
المنشورات للعثور على مصدر موثوق
للمعلومات ،
شارك كل واحد منا
معرفته وموارد التعلم التي حصل عليها في
مجموعات على Facebook ،
حتى أنه كان لدينا الكثير من الأقران
ومناقشة الطالب لكبار السن والتي يمكن إلى
حد ما سد الفجوة بين
التعلم ومصاعب الوصول إلى
الجامعات للطلاب أو مواجهة  مثل هذا
الموقف الآن ، أصبح YouTube YouTube
حرجًا للغاية في حياتنا الدراسية ،
بحثنا عن العديد من المحاضرات حول
كل مفهوم تقريبًا وجدنا صعوبة في
فهمه ، كما قدم مساعدة حاسمة
في تصور الكثير من
المعلومات التي لم نتمكن من
الوصول إليها على أرض الواقع
هناك أيضًا LinkedIn و Cochrane التي
كانت بمثابة شبكات مفتوحة
ربطتنا بالعديد من الباحثين العظماء حول
العالم ، حتى أن بعض هؤلاء الباحثين
تطوعوا في نقل
معارفهم وتوفير بعض
فرص التعلم الآن أنا أعمل على
مراجعة منهجية مع الأساتذة
الذين لدي  لم تقابل أبدًا شخصيًا
والقيام بكل الأعمال عبر الإنترنت ،
يمكنك جميعًا أن تفعل نفس Twitter ويمكن أيضًا
استخدام Twitter للحصول على آخر
الأخبار ومتابعة العديد من
الباحثين والمحترفين الرائعين في
محمصة خبز محمصة مجانية واحدة رائعة أخرى
يمكن للطلاب استخدامها  تستخدم أيضًا MOOCs أو
الدورات التدريبية المفتوحة الضخمة عبر الإنترنت ، فهذه
دورات عبر الإنترنت مقدمة لجميع الطلاب في جميع
أنحاء العالم مجانًا  يمكنك العثور على
الدورات التدريبية ومعظم مجالات التعليم
من أشهر MOOCs المنصات أو
Coursera و EDX وهو دواء
وراوة يمكنك الوصول إليه بسهولة والتسجيل
في دورات عالية الجودة تقدمها العديد
من الجامعات رفيعة المستوى حول العالم
، أعتقد ذلك  MOOCs مفيدة للغاية
ويمكن لجميع الطلاب استخدام
هذه الدورات لتوسيع نطاق
معرفتهم وتعزيز
قدراتهم على التفكير النقدي كتجربة شخصية
لقد تعلمت
الكتابة الأكاديمية بالاعتماد بنسبة 95٪ على MOOCs
والأوراق العلمية عبر الإنترنت عندما بدأت
التعلم
لقد كتبت حالة  أبلغني به وأرسله إلى
أحد كبار السن لي لتقييمه لي
وأخبرني أنه مكتوب بشكل سيء
لدرجة أنه لم يستطع حتى قراءة كل
شيء ولكن الآن بعد عامين من هذا
التعليق القاسي كان لدي ثلاث منشورات وثلاث
أوراق و  المراجعة في
مجلات مختلفة وثلاث أوراق قيد
الإنشاء ويذهب كل الفضل إلى
التعليم الإلكتروني ،
لذا فقد ساعدني الإنترنت حقًا في
صقل قدراتي وأنا  أعتقد
أنه يمكن أيضًا أن يساعد جميع
الطلاب السوريين الذين ما زالوا يتمتعون بإمكانية الوصول إلى الإنترنت في
الحفاظ على عملية تعليمية مناسبة ، ما
عليك سوى أن تكون حريصًا على عدم استخدام
عدم أخذ أي معلومات
تصادفك كأمر مسلم به واستخدام مصادر مرجعية تم التحقق منها فقط.
صُنعت لتوفير المعرفة للجميع في
جميع أنحاء العالم وهي متوفرة
مجانًا لنا فقط لمواصلة التعلم ،
لذلك دعونا الآن نضيع حياتنا ونحن نبكي على
إيماننا ودعونا
نستمر بالطبع في ذلك بفضل الكثير من الأشياء
المدهشة
هناك في الواقع تأخذ وقتًا خارجًا  من
حياتهم الخاصة لإلقاء بعض الضوء على حياتنا ،
لقد وعدتهم بأننا لن نستمر في
استهلاك حياتنا كلها الآن
نتعلم وسننضم إليهم قريبًا في
نشر المعرفة ، لذلك طوال
السنوات الخمس الماضية تحولت حياتنا بشكل غير متوقع
إلى جحيم مشتعل.  من
الصعب للغاية الحفاظ على المسار الصحيح ، لكن
لا ينبغي لنا التوقف عن المقاومة ، يجب أن
نستمر في التمسك بكل فرصة لتعلم
المزيد ولأن نصبح محترفين بدرجة عالية
في المستقبل ،
لا يمكن أبدًا رفض الأشخاص الطموحين مثلكم بأية وسيلة من وسائل
الحياة القاسية ، انظروا هذا نحن هذا هو ما
نحن عليه السوريون ، ليس لدينا أي عذر إذا
كنا غير متعلمين على الرغم من كل
الصعوبات التي واجهناها على الرغم من كل
الخسائر التي تعرضنا لها.  سنبقى على قيد الحياة
وسنواصل النضال من أجل أحلامنا وسنواصل
العمل من أجل حياة أفضل ومستقبل أفضل